-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated actor
and writer
who you know from his work
on "Saturday Night Live,"
"The Last Man on Earth,"
and as the voice
of the Sea Captain.
He stars in the highly
anticipated action-comedy
series "MacGruber,"
which begins streaming
on Peacock December 16th.
Please welcome back to the show
my very good friend
Will Forte, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughs ] Hi, buddy.
-Hi. How are you?
-Good. How have you recovered?
Are you doing alright?
-I went to the corner bistro
after that
and got a delicious burger.
What I didn't know is,
I was already full
before I went there,
so I was like -- I couldn't --
I basically couldn't breathe
till midnight that night.
We did this on Sunday.
-Yeah, well, we walked --
We had some, like,
fried chicken that was on set.
And I feel like we ate a lot
of that 'cause we were so drunk
that we were just talking
and eating way too much chicken.
-But we didn't eat the chicken
until 12 tequila shots in
or something like that.
-So it just was floating.
It wasn't even, like,
being able to be processed.
-Yeah.
-I would like to say...
we had a lot of big, grand plans
of getting together that night.
We were very stereotypically
drunk
because we were like,
"Let's get dinner later."
And you're like,
"I'll text you."
And I was like, "I'll text you."
And then we both went home
and didn't talk again
till today.
-But I thought about you
the whole time.
-I did, too.
-Yes.
-Well, I -- My wife
is one of your biggest fans.
And one of the great memories
I have of getting to be
on set for "MacGruber,"
in 2010, the film,
is that you shot it
in New Mexico,
as you did with the series.
My wife lives -- grew up,
I should say, in New Mexico.
And so we got to hang out,
you, me,
and my soon-to-be in-laws,
because we were
just dating then.
-Yes, you guys were dating.
This was -- I don't know.
I would say maybe a year
into your relationship?
-Two years. My wife --
Based on where you're going,
I want to clarify
it was two years.
-Okay, this is two years,
which makes this story better.
-Yeah, worse for me,
better to tell, yeah.
-Okay, and I apologize Ariel,
your sister-in-law,
is, like, an unwilling
participant in this story.
-Yeah.
-Back in the day,
I was a single man.
-Yeah.
-And Ariel was a single woman.
-We had, one night,
gone to your in-laws --
your in-laws-to-be house.
And we all had a little tequila.
That was another, you know,
tequila night.
And, you know,
we had a little --
Ariel and I had
a little makeout session.
-You guys made out.
-Yeah. So, it was very innocent.
But then we woke up
the next day.
We all stayed at the house,
in separate quarters, everyone,
except -- even you.
You were very chaste back then.
-I was very chaste.
-Anyway, we woke up,
and then we went
to this place called Bobcat.
And as we were driving, Ariel
and I were in the front seat.
You guys, two years
into your relationship,
were into the back.
And you had, at this point,
not yet told Alexi
that you loved her.
-I had not.
That is correct.
-Yeah.
-And I did not realize,
but Ariel had told you that
when I wasn't there.
So this was a piece
of information that you had
that I did not know
that you had.
-Yes. And I seized
upon that information.
And so I made a very big deal
of professing my love to Ariel.
-Yeah.
-In the front seat, just like,
"Ariel,
I'm just going to say it.
When it's time, it's time.
And, you know,
you are so special.
And I just think I'm ready
to tell you right away
that I love you.
Any person who just feels
strongly about somebody
will tell them they love them,
and I just want to do this."
And you're in the back seat
going, "You son of a gun."
-And then,
I'd like to point out,
that wasn't my only terrible
heel-dragging.
So, then we were together
five years,
and I still hadn't proposed.
-Okay.
-And at an "SNL" --
I was at an "SNL" after party.
You'd left "SNL."
And I was at "SNL."
-Screw that place!
Who needs it, right?!
-I know.
I didn't want you
to get into all that.
-Best job ever.
Would not be here without it.
I love you, Lorne.
I love everything about it.
-Alright.
So, I'm at a table,
at the after party,
with Alexi and Ariel again.
-Yeah.
-And you walk in.
I didn't even know
you were coming.
You see us.
Beeline over, take a knee.
-[ Laughter ]
-I forgot this!
-Take a knee to Ariel,
and you're like,
"I want to say something
that I have waited
way too long to say.
Ariel, I love you.
Will you marry me?"
And I was like, "You mother..."
Twice!
-Well, you're married now
with three kids, right?
-With three kids, yeah.
-And I'd like to think
that I have a little
part of that action.
That's a weird way to say that.
-You do have a part
of that action.
-Yeah.
It's all about action to me
and being a part of the action.
You're either a part
of the action or you're not.
Yeah.
-You -- This is so exciting.
So, this was a sketch, a beloved
sketch that became a movie
that I think we can be honest
about the fact
that is beloved now.
People who have discovered
the film in the last 10 years.
-Thank you for saying that.
-Yeah.
-We all know --
-It was not --
It was not beloved at the time.
Or maybe -- You know, maybe
the people who saw it liked it.
-I think they did.
-But definitely not a lot
of people saw it.
We can agree on that for sure.
-Yes, let's just drill down
and say, like, box office-wise
it did not set the world
on fire.
-[Bleep] the bed.
Just like --
I mean, the bed was --
At the end of that
was more [bleep] than bed.
Yeah.
-So it's very exciting
for the fans of this
that it's now not just back,
it's not a sequel,
it's a new series.
It's eight episodes.
What I've seen of it
is so exciting,
being a huge fan of the film.
Did you always --
In the back of your head,
did you and Jorma
and John Solomon
think like, "You know what?
Maybe one day,
we'll make more of these"?
-We pretty immediately after --
You know,
when the dust settled in our
head after a couple of weeks,
it's hard to go through
a situation like that.
But early on, we said,
"You know what?
We're proud of this thing.
Nobody wants a sequel,
but let's give them one.
Let's just frickin' do it."
And we were like, "Even if we
have to shoot it on iPhones,
let's just -- let's do it."
So we immediately started
thinking of titles.
We came up with
the dumbest titles.
-What were some
of the rejected --
-"MacGruber 2:
[Bleep] Infested Waters."
[ Laughter ]
Another one --
Jorma, I think, had
"Hawaiian Gold: MacGruber 2:
The Search for Hawaiian Gold."
[ Laughter ]
Val Kilmer had --
He had a simple one.
"MacTwober."
-"MacTwober."
-Yeah.
And then Wiig, I think, said
"MacGruber Part Deux Part --"
Wait.
"MacGruber Part Deux, Deux."
Just so it could get
"doo-doo" in there.
-I also -- Yeah, somebody
pitched at the time
"MacGruber Goes Number 2"
as a sequel title.
-Oh, that was Wiig also.
-Yeah, that was a really
good one, as well.
This is very exciting.
We're going to show a clip of it
and then talk more about it
when we come back with more
from Will Forte after this.